uh 2024 candidate Donald Trump went to
East Palestine Ohio yesterday and held
an event the event was completely
deranged Trump talked about football
Trump brought Trump water he went to a
McDonald's he told people to have fun
and the entire event was a complete and
total farce that went horribly wrong
right away in this first clip Trump
falsely claims that the Biden
Administration intends to do nothing
about what took place in Ohio but that
his presence there got them to all of a
sudden start doing things that's what it
is this is really America right here
we're standing in America unfortunately
as you know in too many cases your
goodness and perseverance who were met
with indifference and betrayal in some
cases
Biden and FEMA said they would not send
federal aid to
East Palestine under any circumstance
they're not going to send Aid I thought
that was a strange statement because
I've been working with FEMA for a long
time four years and they were great with
us with the tornadoes the hurricanes and
things like this and it was a strange
statement to come out and they were
doing nothing for you they were
intending to do absolutely nothing for
you JD and I spoke and they said they're
not coming they're not going to come and
I said that's very strange FEMA said
specifically this doesn't meet the
criteria and that's horrible and
somebody has to do something for those
people I said back when I announced that
I was coming they changed their tune it
was an amazing phenomena the mayor and I
were discussing that it was quite
amazing what happened and yeah they said
that we can't let this happen
that was a big change of face JD that
you ever see a change like that one that
was a quick yep as you know of course
Trump has an unblemished record as the
beacon of corporate responsibility and
is just the perfect person to really uh
turn to on this issue and hold big
corporations accountable now nothing
that he's saying there is true but he
does have to make himself the center of
attention Trump also says that he
brought Trump water for people even
though when we research it it seems like
Trump water hasn't actually been a thing
for a very long time but what it seems
like it is is Trump gets labels for some
other water and just puts them on it's
all crazy but he says he brought Trump
water for people in East Palestine but
he also brought like lower Quality Water
for them as well in case some people
don't want the Great Water I guess I
don't know especially thanks some of the
incredible people that helped us because
we're bringing thousands of bottle of
water Trump water actually across the
water some of it we had to go to a much
lesser quality water
you want to get those Trump bottles I
think more than anybody else but we're
bringing a lot of women he brought good
water and he also brought lower Quality
Water for people
absolutely Beyond parody the reality of
course in terms of Trump's record on
train regulations is that there were
safety rules put in place by the Obama
Administration for high Hazard cargo
trains which Trump then said oh Obama
did that Obama yes Obama then I'm going
to go ahead and repeal those and that is
exactly what took place Trump then
started ranting about football if you
can believe it you know it reminded me a
little bit I don't know if you remember
when Ohio State wasn't going to be
playing football for another season they
were going to sit back and watch with
the China virus or covet whatever you
want to call it
and I called the head of the Big Ten Big
Ten football I said you got to get this
football open
and they were great they responded and
Ohio State played that season now the
Big Ten denies that Trump had any
involvement in this but it is one of
those stories that Trump loves to repeat
nobody remembers that I think right does
anybody because it didn't happen you
know you got at least one at least one
you couldn't be close but by now you
still would be close probably but we got
that open very early and you had a great
season of football yep all thanks to
Trump of course and then lastly even
though Trump is obese he makes a fat
joke about East Palestine mayor Trent
Conaway saying that he's very easy to
find because he's overweight right so
how could you possibly miss him I also
want to recognize a man who has been
working tirelessly for this community
since the beginning of the Nightmare and
uh Trent where is Trent he's very easy
to find
I do think Trump doesn't see himself as
obese because he so frequently talks
about other people's weight and size uh
while claiming to be 6'3 and weighing
only 239 which uh oh God what is
happening in this country so anyway
there is Trump's very inspiring visit to
East Palestine taking credit for things
he didn't do ignoring his own role in
reducing train regulations uh calling
the mayor fat and then going to
McDonald's and
um I don't know handing out Maga hats as
he did another horrible embarrassment
you can find these clips if you're
morbidly curious about what this all
looked like we'll have these clips up on
our Instagram which you can find by
searching Instagram for David packman
show they'll be on Facebook at
facebook.com davidpackman show and of
course on the YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman and
show one of our sponsors is little spoon
your One Stop Shop for healthy easy
meals and snacks for your baby toddler
or big kid delivered right to your door
little spoon has you covered with fresh
organic baby food for every stage they
have toddler and kids meals that even
the picky eaters will love they have
smoothies for on the go and they just
launched a new product called biteables
which are early finger food meals cut
into bite sizes for easy self-feeding
which will make your transition to the
table food a breeze little spoons baby
food is 100 organic and cold pressed for
every eating stage my daughter loves
those for toddlers and big kids little
spoon has the classics like mac and
cheese but they'll sneak things in like
butternut squash and carrots they're all
kid approved and packed with nutrients
and the best part kids meals are under
six dollars each baby food under three
dollars a serving so it's quick easy and
affordable go to littlespoon.com and
you'll get fifty percent off your first
order with the code Pacman 50 off the
link is down below